frankly I did a bunch of research before
joining Boehner and that was a big part
of my decision to come here was knowing
what Gary's spoke of so to see that he's
walking the walk is really cool not just
talking to talk but I adore you and I'm
giving a wonderful day ricky-rock right
so happy birthday Janaki birthday
there's of us is happy particular
actually we love you Claude
I wanted to just get and we can do this
together I want it you know it's the
same thing from my standpoint when we
had a really great dinner I and the
topic got brought up and probably why I
opened my big mouth and said okay you
wanna if this is so important we want to
be a more important partner there's not
a lot of people that are just gonna be
willing to open up an office ad hoc
quickly just cuz that's the advantage of
being an entrepreneur a lot of mention
today and I'm sure you'll be pooping out
quite a bit through Rock of like
different offices I would have to take
the
scope and reverse-engineer it I'd also
need to speak to the slash as a whole so
I'd like to understand what is available
or not an environment I believe that
vaynermedia needs to very much consider
five six seven eight offices in
different parts of the country that are
not la we're in LA sf London New York I
believe that the IP that we get from
different perspectives not only from
people that grew up in those areas but
by actually being grounded in
Chattanooga Tennessee and these four to
six other cities that are vying you know
it's fun they're buying for vaynermedia
to go there because you know by us
setting up shop there we invite more
entrepreneurial spirit other companies I
bring company there's a lot going on in
Chattanooga that is benefiting us and I
think they're important to vaynermedia
because the clients we have and the
ambitions I have is a businessman long
term I need to be grounded in the IP of
those markets we need to understand what
Sal's DNA is in San Antonio Texas we
need to understand Karen's ambitions and
in Topeka Kansas we need to understand
how Katherine with three kids in this in
Walla Walla Washington thinks about the
world not just the people that role in
LA and so I'm very conscious of that
it's on strategy I plan on putting up
ten flag in cities like that across
America will go international will look
at the Singapore's and Sydney's and and
and the Helsinki's and and the
Montreal's and the Mexico cities and the
same Palos as well and then maybe in a
15 20 year period will start looking at
the suburbs of these major countries as
a as I continue to navigate the growth
in my business career
you heard what is up my man you look at
that leg just so well lay down
are you complaining oh I love confess
right like yeah but dude I gotta be
honest with you like I'm starting to get
weird about it like I I'm a hundred
percent decided that I'm gonna buy a
place out here are you are you but you
know like I swear I'm gonna spend my
hunky la that like you knew ten years
boyfriend big 100 percent look at that
guy he went all black today all black I
love it so much
you good great I'm great it's going on
all good stuff Stuart hey it's Adam what
do you know sometimes want like every
one of these buildings that's crazy
is that what happened early yeah I've
been here a bunch John the whole thing
so it's like but I mean every time I
come there's like six noodle ball
centers there's like six and day one
since then you know a lot of it is like
I think so ad hoc so on the DL are you
hello
that's I like that that Matt that's how
I like this ketchup that's how I like to
ransom how are you Arnie agency came are
you doing nice meting that little
Theodore right that there yeah I
remember that but it but I know I mean I
like PETA the legend my husband i watch
it like all the time he can't get away
for it thank you a little later you know
we're just damming a little better job d
rocks doing here yeah I got in there a
chuckling well for you know I'll falling
apart but I'm hoping I can help if I
start from the bottom here I think I can
help you for hard
no it's poison how you doing nothing
good working
oh I see any rocks gonna be happy
there's like better shots home [ __ ] here
I'll clear that
d-roc is where I like you know who did
it for d-roc did it it's [ __ ] hot
what's the top of Venice
I mean I'm here for this meeting I
surrounded everything else around today
this meeting so I feel so safe because
I'm I have a budding relationship with
him but I feel so safe in your hands
tell me what to do and we will get it
done I don't want to miss this moment
this would be in the way of like in my
career like passing on this would be up
there with passing on uber in the angel
round twice even though that like I
don't I don't joke in the fact that that
probably lost me 250 million dollars I'm
not so sold that if I miss this it
doesn't cost me two hundred fifty
million dollars here's why I just think
that if I do this it will change my life
you know one of the great things about
doing this daily Villa's do you know how
bad I wish that this camera and this
amazing man was with me when I first
walked into Twitter when there was eight
employees there do you know how amazing
that would be like just the history by
the way just the b-roll for
conversations around Twitter or when I
gave that keynote to most of Facebook
when there were much different smaller
company or that first meeting I had with
David Karp talking about my excitement
for where tumblr was going or when I
flew out to meet with Google and Yahoo
about YouTube and Yahoo video or those
that day and in Paris when I first met
Travis the future CEO of uber you know
catching these bureaus of these early
meetings of snapchat two four six eight
years before they will be these one of
the establishments even though in my
mind their establishment again for for
all those small cities or all the 50
year olds that aren't paying attention
they don't know it yet the way I know it
the way I see it and so
I'm passionate about that I'm passionate
about capturing these moments having
those meetings and those early days of
establishing those relationships you
know with the leading platforms in the
world and really showing that framework
for all you entrepreneurs that one of
the great things is when there isn't
anything tangible or anything too crazy
still building those relationships
whether with a Shawn from snapchat or a
Roman from put out they are part of the
day in and day out that matter so much
television is dead this is what matters
and are like in the religion of this
same thesis yeah so alright we'll be in
touch all right
you know what capturing this wing with
that Pete that cool thing by me
many cultures I mean okay what else a
your was kind of laughing and smiling
right now um but it is six o'clock so if
you'll work hard but they have fun
working on a good culture is not
something I want to have because it's
fun for me to talk about publicly or it
makes me feel good a good culture is the
a the right thing to do and does make me
feel good so I guess some contradiction
of myself you know it's funny I made
that little joke like actually that's my
truth I I do like being a good guy or
it's the right thing to do
yeah I mean like like I have a dirty
little secret for you doing the right
thing is always the right thing the idea
of taking the high road and being always
the bigger person is something that you
know has always been such a huge part of
vaynermedia as we've scaled and grown
and now I have all these different
offices it's important to I know how
important it is to Gary but it's been
important to us the group that we're
like the original set to maintain that
culture and what makes it special to
work here and I think for some people
here it was probably not a new message
but still an important one to hear it
and to hear it from Gary from the top
and the fact that it means so much to
him and that it's not just lip service
the culture at Vayner is so strong it
was the first thing I heard about when I
interviewed here and has been pretty
consistently pushed as really important
to the company since I've been here but
I know Gary also believes that going
above and beyond should be the standard
so to hear that we're doing great but we
should be doing better didn't I wasn't
too worried about how we were going to
handle it
we're gonna really see things improve
them here like like it has a funny like
call it [ __ ] Karma
call it whatever the [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
want doing the right thing is the right
thing it always always always ends up in
net score being the right move even if
that net score isn't a micro thing that
happens in a three year window on
business you did something nice they
eventually became your client they gave
you money they're your homie they give
you an opportunity that nobody asked not
that I mean if none of that works out
when you're laying there and sick and
you can feel good about how you lived
your life the ultimate net score you've
won a great culture enable speed when
you genuinely like each other and when
you genuinely understand that all of you
have the right intent in mind that
you're not doing this because you want
to get the ribbon or the recognition or
the promotion or whatever else or just a
good person you're not mean or clicky or
whatever it [ __ ] is when there's a
good culture speed happens when you're
not spending extra time figuring out why
Matt is trying to ruin you right then
you're in a really good place so yes do
I think that in every situation you
should try to be the bigger woman or man
do the right thing be the nicer person
be the better person yes I believe in
that yes I tried to achieve that and I
try you don't always do it but I try
that intent is real I thought it went
really well
I think it's really important for us to
always keep in mind that culture is what
makes this agency as awesome as it is
and it's sort of always the backbone of
what keeps us going so I think it's a
good constant reminder for people on the
west coast and people in New York just
to hear it time and time again the
culture that I have sensed already here
is truly exceptional and it's um it's a
place where people want to be at least
that's been my experience and people are
excited to be here they're enjoying the
work and I don't want to be anywhere
where that's not the case and this is
truly and the first place where I've
that from the majority of the people in
the office so it's great I mean I have
like the Vayner culture like fully
ingrained in me from being there New
York and I was really really happy when
he did this thing and I found out about
it because I was like the one thing that
I talked to him about was like getting
him and Claude and you know like James
and Scott here more often for like per
like one-on-one in-person meetings
because it's just so much different
having that leadership available to you
in New York and like we just don't see
those people like on a day-to-day basis
here so when he said that he was like
I'm gonna be here more often and I'm
think about buying a house and whatever
you know like that is gonna be awesome
just having him here and it's going to
make this place so much better than it
already is
it's interesting because you mentioned
about culture you know as far as I'm
concerned coming in from startups and
very large companies other
the culture here is pretty exceptional
yep so what is it that it's going to
change and what is it that you're not
seeing
yeah so it is exceptional and I want you
guys to know that I just don't want one
person saying something mean about
anybody ever ever ever how about that my
question to him was well if you want it
to be better what do you feel is missing
because I wanted to know um kind of just
maybe digging a little deeper and
understand further how do you take
something um that's good and make it
great so that was kind of where my
question was coming from but um but the
fact that he is someone who's not just
okay with good who wants to take it to
the next level is something I really
respect and I want to be working for
someone like that someone who has a
vision and someone who sees that there's
always an opportunity to continually
improve and iterate I mean I think it's
about evolving too if knowing that as a
company grows the things have to evolve
and just because a company gets bigger
doesn't mean that that culture has to
suffer so I love that he has that vision
and that's again certainly someone that
I want to be working for who believes
that I know that the culture here is
phenomenal I'm pumped that you must be
sitting there merely roof-like because
because I know and you guys all know
like we know but just imagine where the
[ __ ] on that right like and listen I'm
not listening on the flip side of what I
just said I don't think it's humanly
natural for what I just asked for right
like I like I get it but I do think I
want you guys to understand if that's
the ambition that you need to save that
for when it's really needed does that
make sense like it just can't be easy to
talk [ __ ] you know it's funny I've been
writing a lot of articles about
entrepreneurship do you know how tough
it is when you have nobody else to blame
how much fun it is for you to blame the
person that's above you
pretty cool no fun it is to blame Matt
it's fun you know fun is for Matt to
blame me it's fun like like for me it's
not fun there is nobody else like I
promise you every single thing that is
broken here is my fault
sucks super lonely when you have to make
this core decision you know
look it's my responsibility like like
it's my job like just like I talked
about as you just saw in the clip of
shorty rocks editing it nicely just like
I talked about like it is lonely at the
top it's only my responsibility every
issue at the company is my fault and so
you know you allocate the hour and a
half to give that talk for the whole
company and you miss four phone calls
that were going on and dear I kept
looking at me during that time and you
know because it's only my responsibility
it's only my singular responsibility
with the clods and the James and the
seagulls they're there but at the end of
the day the buck stops with me and I
have to at every with with every ounce
of my soul try to deploy my Northstar to
my employees no and it is it is my
challenge and every leaders challenge
all of your challenges to know that
moment when you got to give that talk
like I knew it was time for that talk
and I know there's gonna be benefit from
it and I've gotten the email here's a
post game from it six hours ago I've
gotten like five emails already good
ones real ones
and so it's meaningful you got to put in
the work and so it's it's a leaders
number-one job to deploy her or his
religion on everybody underneath them
from their right-hand man or woman all
the way down to the intern that started
yesterday and you've got to do that in a
million different ways and for me I try
to put my self in a position to win so
not all of you are going to be able to
or have the charisma or the natural
communication talent to do an all
hands-on meeting but many of you can
write a manifesto this incredible
five-page article PDF blog post that
moves your company some of you can voice
it some of you can do an off-site at a
cabin that you own and
that's it some of you can pick the four
people that can get it from you and then
they're the ones that instill it you've
got to figure out your version to
communicate that installation of your
religion to your organization but you
can't just put your head in the sand and
not do it because you don't do it the
way you saw me do it or the way you
heard somebody else do it
figure it out write a manual do a
seminar you know anoint for
communicators within that translate you
the best I don't care but do it you know
it's always great just having Gary in
the building you know I have had the
luxury of knowing him for ten years plus
and I know how he ticks but not
everybody that's in this office
especially gets that kind of access to
him so just having him here I think
really makes a huge difference and the
fact that he's going to be here so much
more often over the coming weeks and
months will mean a lot to the
development growth of this office if you
think about everything that's going on
is like you kind of have to be the
bigger person or you just look dumb a
great culture enables speed when you
genuinely like each other and when you
genuinely understand that all of you
have the right intent in mind that
you're not doing this because you want
to get the ribbon or the recognition or
the promotion or whatever else we're
just a good person you're not mean or
clicky or whatever it [ __ ] is when
there's a good culture speed happens
when you're not spending extra time
figuring out why Matt is trying to ruin
you right then you're in a really good
place I want I've done a much more
aggressive job in New York on this issue
I want to make sure everybody
understands in this office how much it
matters to me and how much it is the
single reason most people get fired at
vaynermedia and how much I would like to
elevate what we have going on here we
have a great thing going on here it's
not where I wanted to be and so I want
to make sure everybody understands that
being the bigger man and being the
bigger woman in every situation all of
them is the prerequisite it's not the
ambition it's not what I hope we get to
it's the cost of entry
and points are being tallied on the
individuals in this room that are not
playing that game on an everyday basis
it is the thing I care about you can get
away with it for four months seven
months even a year but you just can't
get away for with it long term and so I
highly recommend that you use Madalena
that use Clawd that use me that use mat
that use your homies whatever you need
to use to make sure whatever is
bothering you that doesn't allow you to
be in that mental place to be that
teammate to always look the reason it's
easy to be the bigger man and women in
any situation is you're happy with
yourself first you're in a good place it
gives you the audacity and the mental
strength and the stomach to be able to
be the bigger person guys I'm always
right you know or at least I think so
and so and so when I have to be the
bigger man a lot of situations it's
quite hard for me and I also have the
track record and the experience and the
results to like back my [ __ ] up and I
still have to be [ __ ] on an every day
basis for me to do what I'm asking you
to do so I promise you if I do it every
day with clients and AJ and James and
Claude and Scott and Matt if I do it
then I promise you I expect you to do it
no matter who you are what you do or
what your [ __ ] title says you are and
so to make that happen I need to make
sure there's not a click or an
individual or four random individuals
that are going to stop it from happening
the way that I want it to happen I'm
available for you if you're concerned
about what I'm saying and you know it's
predicated by you being upset about your
pay your opportunity the other person on
your team 700 other things that could
come up that make you not as in the best
places you could be which then creates a
scenario where you are not I'd much
rather you be on the offense with me I
fix it and or we talk about it then for
you to just go down the inevitable path
of not being happy not being able to be
that person that the company wants and
I'm just being battered that's not
for you and I'm very thankful that you
have this company and that you believe
in me it the logo team so I want to be
there for you some super available Gary
at vaynermedia
wide open super pumped so and again I'm
going to be back here next week like I'm
gonna be here a lot and so I have
enormous ambition for what we're doing
out here we um we have a lot going on
and a lot of very good stuff going on
and and I need to I need to elevate the
level of everything here starting with
culture real culture not you're doing it
on the surface but you don't mean it
got it
feel really good about the talk I just
gave to the LA crew no obviously new
challenges satellite offices Wine
Library was only one location so I
myself as an entrepreneur I'm developing
and I don't talk a lot about my
shortcomings very often because I really
don't give them a whole lot of thought
but I definitely recognize my need to be
present physically in in some of the
offices which I'm exciting and la is
becoming a very important very important
this week I shot through Miami la is
becoming a very important hub for us and
I think that there was some stuff going
on in the office that could go from a
nine point two to a ten point one and so
that was what you know even though the
tone was like cultural culture la is
doing its thing I just want to be better
and like I always make that joke of like
the people that don't do innovation
they're like but business is up sixty
percent
well what about 120 what about 400 so
that's what that was it's not that I'm
worried about culture it's that I just
want it to be better right guys hi right
yeah yes was that good you guys will
join talk good awesome
have a great day thank you I'll see you
guys in a week